is he Kanye has broken out of his
thought prison and the left hates it
even though they claim to be against
mass incarceration of black men because
they're hypocrites and the best part is
Kanye triggered all the snowflake
lefties with only seven little words I
love the way Candace Owens thinks great
I completely agree but what am i
agreeing with here to share some insight
is citizen journalist Nicole Thurmond
[Applause]
Jordan Jordan this is a victory for
freethinkers everywhere and when it
comes to provoking the left Kanye have
got nothing on Candace the NRA was
started as a civil rights organization
training black Americans to arm
themselves
Alysse brutality is not an issue that is
facing the black community whatsoever
news flash
everybody hates feminism don't you find
it interesting that there are no Jews
lined up throwing yarmulke at the White
House we're rioting like fools in the
street you wanna know why that is
it's because they're educated Wow it's
like she's willing to loudly say every
thought that your grandmother's only
been whispering for years
Candace Owens wants us to know that the
only thing holding black people back is
our obsession with the past come on
if systemic oppression was real when
there have been some huge sweeping
change by now to address it as a nation
no being a victim is a choice like being
gay or tall take a candy I don't know
why people like being oppressed so
weirdest thing I've ever heard I love
oppression
we're oppressed 400 years of slavery Jim
Crow which by the way none of you guys
lived through your grandparents didn't
it's embarrassing that you utilize you
utilize their history you're not living
through anything right now you're overly
privileged yep I'm with her you're not
living through anything right now black
people so stop whining about Starbucks
charlottesville the Waffle House
incident the other Waffle House incident
the golfcourse incident that unarmed
black guy getting shot the other 23
unarmed black guys getting shot the
appropriation of coconut oil and Kim
Zolciak return to the Real Housewives of
Atlanta this season
just check your priveledge black people
yes people are so confused but the truth
is conservatives and Donald Trump truly
are the best for black people in fact
it's getting hard to see in here let me
get out my trusty gas lights you know
what no no no I got this Jordan mm-hmm
[Music]
black people black people the left has
been lying to us we're not stronger
together we're stronger as individuals
you don't have to be a Democrat
what is Barack Obama ever done for you I
mean for you personally hezbollah co
Bhama ever helped you move did he give
you a ride to the airport did he even
show up to your Christmas party no
Barack Obama waged a war on Christmas
remember of course you do black people
it's time to lay down our burdens like
civil rights they're so heavy
[Music]
stop kneeling for the anthem don't your
knees hurt I don't mind why do we even
have knees it seems like someone just
started making a leg and got a little
tired halfway what are you so upset
about
oh you can't remember Nicole the cook
Nicole what why are you stirring your
tea so weird
don't worry Jordan it's not for you all
that matters is
[Applause]
[Music]